merci d'être avec nous normalement
accompagné pendant cette première
demi-heure et lui de l'Essonne membre du
groupe les républicains apporteur du
budget de l'audiovisuel dont on va
longuement parler mais d'abord un mot
sur Caroline caillot on l'a vu elle a
démissionné hier des missions un peu
surprise de la Ministre chargée des
collectivités en raison d'une
déclaration de patrimoine sous-évaluée
c'est une ancienne LR elle est élue
locale est-ce qu'elle était une bonne
ministre des collectivités vous
regrettez sa démission non je ne
regrette pas cette émission de en
quelques mois elle n'a pas montré quand
même un grand élan ou une volonté de
changer les choses par ailleurs si vous
voulez dans ce genre de non-événement à
mon sens je n'arrive pas à comprendre
encore alors que nous sommes passés au
crible tous les jours que tout le monde
peut te connaître notre patrimoine je ne
comprends pas encore qu'il n'y ait pas
un service qui soit capable quand on
nomme quelqu'un ministre de regarder si
en tout cas tout ça bien évidemment
concours
que là la Haute Autorité a bien entendu
qu'on se donne un petit peu de temps
qu'on passe au crible et une fois parce
que en termes de confiance vous imaginez
ce que ça va rapprocher les Français de
des politiques vous imaginez les dégâts
que ça fait c'est juste incroyable non
événement passons à autre chose et on va
passer à autre chose on va passer au
Sénat justement qui poursuit l'examen du
budget on va parler des crédits de
l'audiovisuel puisque vous en êtes le
rapporteur notre journaliste Alex pousse
à nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonjour et Alex les sénateurs ont adopté
le budget de la culture et notamment
celui de l'audiovisuel public
Radio France médiamonde avec notamment
RFI et France 24 et son budget pour
l'année prochaine augmente 3,8 milliards
d'euros une enveloppe supplémentaire de
114 millions d'euros qui est quand même
un petit peu en dessous de l'inflation
mais pour la gauche ça ne suffit pas car
il y a eu des baisses de moyens ces
dernières années et puis l'enjeu de
l'information est crucial écouter le
socialiste David Assouline
le budget que vous nous proposez estompe
l'oeil il semble aller dans le bon sens
avec une eau s'afficher pour cette
mission mais c'est de l'affichage car
non seulement cette augmentation est
deux fois moins importante que
l'inflation c'est donc une baisse mais
en ce qui concerne audiovisuel public il
ne corrige pas la gigantesque baisse
depuis 5 ans qu'il a réduit à l'os au
moment où il est plus que nécessaire au
contraire de lui donner de l'oxygène
voilà il senteur de gauche qui ne sont
pas satisfaits alors dans ce débat se
pose aussi la question du financement de
l'audiovisuel public qui était jusque là
financé par la redevance télé que les
Français payaient chaque année 138 euros
mais le gouvernement a supprimé cet été
cette redevance télé pour favoriser le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et à la
place l'exécutif prévoit d'utiliser une
fraction du produit de la TVA pour
financer l'audiovisuel public là encore
les sénateurs de gauche ne sont pas
satisfaits car ils estiment que la TVA
est un impôt injuste qui pèse sur les
couches les plus populaires de la
société ils ont donc proposé une
nouvelle redevance progressif que chacun
parait en fonction de ses moyens mais ce
n'est pas du goût du ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal on
l'écoute je suis défavorable aux
augmentations d'impôts et qu'en ce
moment même 23 millions de Français
devraient recevoir un avis de taxe de
138 euros et il ne reçoivent et ils ne
le reçoivent pas parce qu'on a supprimé
la redevance audiovisuelle et donc au
final la majorité de droite et du centre
du Sénat a donné un avis favorable à ce
budget de l'audiovisuel public pour 2023
mais les sénateurs de droite attend une
vraie réforme ambitieuse de
l'audiovisuel public et pas seulement
des retouches financières écoutez Roger
carotché
on ne se remet pas en cause sur le
contour le périmètre du service public
sur les missions du service public et on
ne parle que d'argent
combien bah c'est simple on prend le
budget de l'année d'avant on rajoute
deux ou trois pour cent puis l'année
d'après on fait la même chose puis la
même chose puis la même chose sans
jamais redéfinir les missions du service
public est-ce qu'on attend du service
public et Madame la Ministre est
clairement c'est un avis favorable one
shot si je peux me permettre en anglais
voilà on avertissement qui est donné par
le sénateur de droite Roger carothschi
Jean Raymond Gonnet pour qu'on comprenne
bien la position de la majorité
sénatoriale le budget est plutôt
satisfaisant mais il y a un manque
d'ambition pour l'audiovisuel public me
permettez-vous avant de répondre à la
question de deux petites modifications
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
d'abord le service public faut pas
oublier Lina et Arte font partie voilà
bien sûr et deuxièmement c'est pas le
gouvernement qui a supprimé
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
c'est le président de la République en
campagne qui a annoncé à la donc je
préférais le préciser parce que c'est
quand même lui qui dirige une promesse
de gouvernement voilà contrairement
alors donc
vous regrettez pas du tout ou pas ah non
pas du tout pas du tout je ne fais pas
de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public une vache sacrée le problème
n'est pas là pour l'audiovisuel public
français voilà alors la question le
budget Roger caoutchi vous le savez nous
avons commis un rapport ensemble au bout
de juin voilà parfaitement en ligne
il y a 3% supplémentaires alors David
Assouline a beau dire que le compte
n'est pas effectivement avec l'inflation
avec le fait que certaines structures
sont maintenant sous le coup de la TVA
alors qu'elle ne l'était pas d'autres
l'était sont plus
la taxe sur les salaires tout ça on va
voir en 2023 en tout cas la ministre a
pris les engagements y compris en séance
comme elle l'avait fait auprès de nous
de dire nous compenserons voilà donc il
y a une augmentation dans ce budget le
problème n'est encore pas budgétaire le
problème c'est qu'on perd du temps et
que pendant cinq ans avec une majorité
absolue le président de la République
n'a pas réformé le audiovisuel public
français je ne vois pas comment pendant
5 ans avec une majorité relative il va
pouvoir le faire mais alors pourquoi
faut-il leur réformer restructurer
l'audiovisuel public français alors que
certains groupes marchent plutôt bien
par exemple Radio France les audiences
sont bonnes et bien parce qu'on ne peut
pas encore une fois demander demander à
des structures de l'audiovisuel public
de faire toujours plus
sur le même schéma qu'elles ont fait
avec le numérique en plus et un budget
qui est un budget limite quand David
Assouline dit ils sont à l'os ils sont à
l'OS pour travailler comme ils ont
travaillé pendant des années le sujet
est de travailler comment on va pouvoir
s'inscrire dans l'avenir alors comment
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce qu'il faut
supprimer des entités ce qu'il faut
supprimer des chaînes la première des
choses à faire avant de savoir puisqu'on
parle le budget la question est toujours
posée à l'envers c'est à dire on parle
du budget avant de parler des missions
du périmètre et de la gouvernance pour
nous il faut d'abord définir les réelles
missions du service public le covid a
montré que le service public est
absolument indispensable dans notre pays
voilà pour ceux qui ce qui n'étaient pas
forcément le cas avant le covid
rappelez-vous les débats
l'audiovisuel public est absolument
nécessaire maintenant il faut lui
trouver un vrai périmètre y a-t-il trop
de chaînes trop d'antenne trop voilà ça
pour nous oui donc il faut réduire ce
périmètre et permettre à ce moment là
c'est le développement sur le numérique
parce que sur le numérique hormis Arte
et Radio France qui ont deux réussites
majeures les podcasts et Arte et Arte
qui voudraient aller plus loin avec sa
plateforme européenne et le gouvernement
français ne lui en donne pas les moyens
je le dis au passage mais d'avancer sur
le numérique on peut pas me dire que
c'est
non seulement en retard mais on peut pas
dire que salto soit une réussite si vous
voulez sauf voilà hein et on va
d'ailleurs en parler puisque vous savez
que TF1 M6 sont annoncé leur désir de de
quitter ce triptyque donc ça veut dire
que il faut que français les mettre plus
sur le numérique et qui ne supprime des
chaînes TNT c'est ce que vous dites
lesquels
si on avait nous la science infuse ce
que l'on dit c'est qu'aujourd'hui
reproduire le même schéma va reproduire
toujours les mêmes problèmes et on aura
toujours ce problème d'argent et il
faudra toujours plus parce qu'on ne peut
pas faire autrement donc aujourd'hui il
faut conduire le périmètre donner au
service public des identifiants très
précis et notamment retirer la publicité
sur les chaînes de l'audiovisuel public
toute la journée voilà et on se portera
pas plus mal
une question une autre question une
dernière question peut-être sur cet
échec de la fusion TF1 M6 est-ce que ça
pose un problème pour le paysage de
français ah bah forcément ce qui pose
problème c'est un échec avant c'est un
échec à bon sens avant même
l'audiovisuel public
français c'est l'audiovisuel en général
la réforme de la loi de 86 est
absolument impérative personne ne
souhaite le faire Franck Riester si
était essayé c'était passé devant la
commission Culture à l'Assemblée
nationale avec succès nous nous aurions
puisqu'il reprenait bon nombre des idées
du Sénat dans le rapport le le gatolin
nous serions certainement excusez-moi
l'expression améliorer le texte mais on
aurait sorti quelque chose aujourd'hui
il n'y a rien on est sur une loi de 86
qui a été modifiée je crois plus de 80
fois elle est à bout de souffle c'est ça
le problème central tant qu'on ne
réformera pas et la loi de 86 et à
l'intérieur de cette loi l'audiovisuelle
publique française bien peur qu'on soit
toujours devant des des bas d’experts au
moment
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a trop de monde
aujourd'hui
la première question c'est à dire pour
quelle mission aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas nier que depuis 2018 il y a une
baisse une trajectoire baissière
financière les structures se sont mises
à jour Radio France a fait un plan de
départ volontaire qui a été très
important rappelez-vous les 70 jours
degré qu'il y a eu à ce moment-là donc
on sait que la trajectoire abaissière
mais c'est pas un but en soi de dire il
faut au moins de monde non c'est pour
faire quoi et une fois qu'on aura défini
pour faire quoi on saura le nombre
d'équivalent en plein qu'il faut mettre
en face
Alex on va parler d'un autre sujet
rapidement de ce qui a été débattuir
puisque dans le cadre du budget les
sénateurs vont déposer un amendement
pour imposer la transparence sur le
recours du gouvernement cabinet de
conseil mais oui souvenez-vous à la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur les
cabinets de conseils avaient révélé le
recours excessif à ces sociétés souvent
étrangères de la part de
l'administration publique et pour et
bien réguler ce recours au cabinet
conseil les sénateurs ont voté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi et
puis il prévoit une autre mesure dans le
cadre de ce budget 2023 il souhaite
qu'il y ait une publication annuelle
d'un document qui retracerait l'ensemble
des prestations fournies à l'état par
ces fameux cabinets de conseils une
proposition qui intervient alors que
l'affaire McKinsey est relancé depuis la
semaine dernière puisque le parquet
national financier avait ouvert deux
enquêtes la semaine dernière en tout cas
on l'a appris la semaine dernière sur le
recours à des cabinets de conseils
notamment au cabinet américain McKinsey
dans les campagnes électorales
d'Emmanuel Macron avec des soupçons de
le financement de campagne illégale
également de favoritisme Jean Raymond
Hugonnet ce que vous pensez que cette
affaire mckins relancée peut fragiliser
le sommet de l'État alors fragiliser je
ne sais pas on verra la suite la suite
judiciaire donnée à cela ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que le ce qui me
paraît le plus important là dedans c'est
que qu'on fasse appel à des cabinets et
pourquoi pas mais avec le nombre de haut
fonctionnaires que nous avons de gens
brillantissime qui connaissent les
sujets avec l'administration centrale
pesante que nous avons dans notre pays
est-ce qu'on doit passer autant de fois
sur des cabinets conseils ça me rappelle
une chose vous voyez modestement sur
l'élu locale qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
les intercommunalités on a créé des
intercommunalités donc on a créé des
structures avec des sièges sociaux des
personnels voilà et bien souvent dès que
se pose une grande question le pcaet
d'autres d'autres singeries qui sortent
comme ça et bien on va chercher des
cabinets conseils
à chaque fois à chaque fois donc des
cabinets conseils oui parce que s'ils
existent et qu'il y a une compétence
mais dans quelle mesure dans quelle
limite un petit peu de pudeur
exactement ce sera le débat du club on
va aller dans votre département j'aurais
la qualité du côté de l'Essonne on
retrouve tes 10 Maury bonjour Teddy
merci d'être avec nous rédacteur en chef
du Républicain de l'Essonne était dit
vous souhaitiez relayer une inquiétude
de terrain autour du filet de sécurité
mis en place par le gouvernement pour
soutenir les collectivités
en effet il y a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
sur ce sujet et les mers demandent
vraiment qui va en bénéficier
aujourd'hui on est ça on serait une
trentaine de communes qui recevraient le
soutien de l'État alors que voilà le la
crise de l'énergie touche tout le monde
donc la question qui se pose monsieur le
sénateur monsieur Gonet est-ce que c'est
les critères du filet de du filet de
sécurité ne sont pas trop étroits est-ce
qu'on ne va pas laisser de nombreuses
communes de nombreuses interco
finalement sur le côté voilà face à la
crise énergétique alors ce qu'il faut
dire bonjour d'abord à Teddy voory et
saluer le républicain
écoutez ce qu'il faut bien dire d'abord
c'est que tout ça se finance avec du
déficit nous n'avons pas le moindre
centime en France pour régler ça donc il
faut quand on prend des décisions
surtout en tant que législateur
je pense que le gouvernement on est
conscient également donc le gouvernement
a sorti une première étape en 20 saison
2 nous avons comme vous le savez changer
cet été pour essayer justement dès la
fin de limiter les mailles du filet
plutôt
et en 2023 c'est exactement ce que nous
avons fait c'est à dire que clairement
alors qu'on s'apercevait que 22 000
communes devaient être concernées on
s'apercevait que sur le terrain il y en
avait un nombre limité effectivement en
Essonne il y en a environ une trentaine
entre les communes et certains syndicats
ce que nous avons fait au Sénat c'est de
pouvoir abaisser les effets de seuil
c'est exactement comme pour les impôts
quand vous dépassez de quelques voilà et
élargir les choses et surtout que la
prime ne soit pas donnée aux mauvais
élève c'est à dire qu'à un moment il y
avait des conditions sur la perte
d'épargne Brute et le potentiel
financier des communes qui sortaient du
dispositif des communes qui avaient un
petit peu d'argent de côté mais elle le
faisait pas pour pour faire uniquement
de la trésorerie et rester elle le
faisait parce qu'elles avaient un projet
qu'elles allaient réaliser dans un an ou
deux et elle travaillait si vous ne
passez l'expression en bon père de
famille donc il fallait pas que ces
critères c'était le cas à l'époque on
avait sorti enfin le gouvernement avait
sorti une usine à gaz ce que nous avons
fait aujourd'hui dans le PLF 2023 c'est
justement d'élargir les conditions pour
que plus de communes y est axé et pas
forcément des petites communes je vous
donne juste un détail sur les 10 emplois
qui était prévu avant vous savez les les
communes qui avaient moins de 2 millions
de budget et moins de 10 emplois ce sont
des équivalents temps plein alors
quelles sont les communes les petites
communes avec des îles avec 10
équivalents temps plein donc toutes ces
seuils ont été bougés je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que sinon
c'est quand même il faut le relire à
trois fois c'est assez complexe mais
l'objet c'est vraiment d'élargir le
dispositif en plus du bouclier en plus
de l'amortisseur infidèle sécurité
j'espère que les communes seront encore
une fois bien protégés
d'inquiétude en plus c'est la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises il y a
désormais fameux CVAE
en effet vous venez de le dire monsieur
le sénateur l'État n'a plus l'argent
donc voilà ça fait des années qu'on
incite les intercommunalités à
développer l'économie pour voilà
développer leur ressources via le levier
CVAE aujourd'hui si on le supprime bah
voilà plus aucune visibilité pour les
intercommunalités sur le développement
de leurs ressources et en plus voilà
plus aucune motivation pour développer
l'emploi sur le territoire vous pensez
que c'est une bonne idée cette
suppression alors là c'est un c'est un
sujet kafkaïen pourquoi parce que quand
on sait comme moi que et comme d'autres
que la vie c'est l'entreprise s'il y a
pas d'entreprises s'il y a pas de
développement économique il y a pas de
territoire c'est très clair donc là ce
que nous avons fait nous avons supprimé
la suppression on la supprimé l'article
5 qui supprimer justement
CVAE entre les centres et les
républicains
a donc supprimé l'article 5 c'est la
suppression de la suppression
vous me suivez maintenant ce que l'on
souhaite encore une fois c'est que quand
on nous parle de compensation parce que
ça arrivera sans doute il faudra aussi à
ce moment-là s'assurer que les communes
sont bien protégées comme une et
Communauté de Communes puisque vous
savez que le développement économique
est une compétence intercommunale mais
par par répercussion ça touche forcément
les communes donc là l'équilibre est
très difficile à trouver entre la
volonté d'entendre les entreprises et
effectivement quand même dans notre pays
l'entreprise est souvent pris pour une
vache à lait donc de bien entendre ce
que nous disent les entreprises au
moment où elles souffrent le plus mais
d'entendre aussi les communes et de
trouver cet équilibre nécessaire voilà
c'est pas voilà c'est une un chemin qui
est long mais en tout cas notre volonté
vous le savez au Sénat c'est pouvoir ne
pas déséquilibrer les budgets d'une
façon brutale comme c'était le cas d'une
façon brutale de déséquilibrer les
projets des interco et des communes
parce que sinon on ne peut pas s'en
sortir surtout dans le dans le contexte
d'aujourd'hui
dy mercatoon découvrez le quotidien du
psychique
c'est à dire cette semaine dans le
Républicain de l'Essonne merci beaucoup
Teddy puisqu'on parlait de la CVAE Jean
Raymond Gonesse ce matin dans une
interview parisien Valérie Pécresse fait
le lien entre cette suppression de la
CVAE et ce qu'elle demande aux
entreprises pour financer les transports
franciliens il manque 750 millions elle
demande l'augmentation de la
contribution des entreprises disant que
c'est à peine 10% de cette baisse de la
CV elle a raison
alors Valérie Pécresse est quelqu'un
d'efficace vous voyez et quand elle a
une idée en tête voilà pour le faire
changer d'idée il faut se lever de
bonheur
elle est aujourd'hui à la tête d'Île de
France mobilité et qui rencontre des
probable des problèmes graves elle a
fait ce qu'il fallait pour maintenir les
transports au moment où notre pays en
avait le plus besoin le compte financier
n'y est pas mais ça fait très longtemps
qu'on entend ce sujet je pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle fait cette
proposition qui est qui est fondée très
clairement parce que c'est 750 millions
ils vont manquer donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faut à ce moment la répercuter ses
augmentations sur le Pass Navigo et
faire qu'aujourd'hui ça soit pas les
gilets jaunes mais ça soit des gilets
d'une autre couleur parce que les gens
ne peuvent plus se déplacer donc il faut
que ça soit les entreprises qui paye il
faut que ça soit tant que ça sera ou les
uns ou les autres qui seront censés
payer ça ne fonctionne pas il faut à ce
moment là qui je vais pas dire un
Grenelle mais consentante avec l'État
les entreprises une collectivité pour
savoir une répartition juste et
équitable et solidaire ça ne pourra pas
être les uns contre les autres mais
c'est possible parce que pour le moment
on a l'impression que c'est ça parce que
Valérie Pécresse a dit que s'il y a pas
sa documentation le Pass Navigo devra
passer à 90 euros pour les françaisiens
elle dit dans cette interview l'État
semble indifférent au sort des voyageurs
franciliens et Clément bon le ministre
transport lui dit que cette hausse est
injustifiée que dans les autres régions
notamment une site Carole Delga et
Xavier Bertrand il y a pas
d'augmentation et que Valérie Pécresse
doit assumer ses responsabilités
fort sympathique mais je langage quand
même à avoir ce que c'est que la région
Île-de-France par rapport aux autres
régions françaises en les respectant
toutes dans leur spécificité mais on ne
peut pas traiter on ne peut pas dire oui
la région Île-de-France c'est une région
comme les autres c'est le moteur
principal de notre pays donc la
difficulté c'est que quand vous arrivez
dans un débat en hémicycle sur un thème
comme celui-ci et que vous êtes
francilien c'est très difficile parce
que qui ne sont pas de la région
Île-de-France forcément peuvent penser
qu'il y en a toujours pour
l'Île-de-France ces sujets là il faut
les aborder de façon apaisée aujourd'hui
c'est un dialogue de sourd Valérie
Pécresse a raison de mettre le sujet sur
la table parce que la responsabilité
n'est pas que celle de la région l'État
doit arrêter de faire le sourd et
croyez-moi depuis un moment là aussi
l'état se charge bien de laisser parce
qu'ils savent très bien l'embarras
politique dans lequel va se trouver
Valérie Pécresse si elle est obligée
d'augmenter des tarifs voilà c'est une
manière de la mettre dans une forme
d'embarras politique
bien évidemment bien évidemment on va
parler justement des républicains alors
vous êtes membre du groupe mais pas
membre du parti oui que ce soit clair
vous soutenez quand même un candidat
avec attention je n'ai pas ma carte mais
je soutiens Bruno Retailleau depuis le
début de sa campagne selon un sondage au
dos que ça pour les chaînes
parlementaires et la presse régionale le
candidat qui a la plus forte côte
d'adhésion c'est Éric Ciotti auprès des
sympathisants LR sympathisants et pas
militants puisque évidemment il peut y
avoir de sondage auprès
41% Bruno retaille au 27% Aurélien
Pradier 17%, est-ce que pour vous Eric
Ciotti est favori dans cette élection et
puisque vous soutenez Bruno Retailleau
est-ce que il y aurait un risque de
droitisation du parti sélection-t-il
encore écoutez sur les trois candidats
qui se présentent il y a eu un débat
l'autre jour ils sont en campagne les
uns et les autres pour ma part vous
m'interrogez je trouve qu'il y en a un
qui a beaucoup plus de profondeur
beaucoup plus de sens dans ce qu'il dit
beaucoup plus de sujets traités et de
façon globale avec un vrai projet c'est
Bruno Retailleau je le connais depuis
longtemps je l'ai comme président de
groupe et je sais comment il se comporte
et je sais surtout
ça son attention à rassembler voilà une
famille politique
ericautier quelqu'un de valeur il a
remporté les primaires pour la
présidentielle donc c'est pas une paille
non plus
il est arrivé deuxième il était au
premier tour il était quoi
remporté le premier tour mais mais du
coup ça veut dire que vous vous reteniez
vous dites il aura pas la même capacité
de rassemblement avec ce titre je pense
qu'il est plus clivant parce qu'il a un
langage et lui-même a construit et
encore une fois il raconte il a un récit
qui est intéressant et plus profond
aussi des fois que que certains
voudraient dire parce que c'est une
caricature rapidement il faut bien
l'écouter alors après il fait de
certaines thématiques des thématiques
qu'il voilà qu'il a en répétition et je
pense que ça ne peut pas s'arrêter là
même si c'est aujourd'hui un des sujets
qui en France est très problématique je
parle de l'immigration et de la sécurité
voilà il y a aussi autre chose dans ce
sondage c'est 45% des sympathisants LR
sont favorables à une alliance avec la
majorité présidentielle 45% c'est quand
même près de la moitié c'est aussi votre
avis alors il faut réfléchir à cette
alliance c'est dans cette question la
question que vous posez tout à l'heure
sur la droitisation aujourd'hui il est
certain que par rapport à ce qui se
développe le gouvernement et le
rassemblement national par exemple et
Nuxe à partir du moment où il y a cette
radicalisation et au milieu quelque
chose de d'assez mou de le en même temps
et bien vous avez une propension parce
que les choses ne s'améliorent pas une
propension des gens à aller de plus en
plus vers des extrêmes et la droite ne
voilà est exactement dans ce même
mouvement donc oui le risque existe
en ce qui me concerne c'est pas ça la
direction à suivre merci un mot de foot
puisque vous êtes un grand fan de foot
c'est compliqué cette Coupe du monde en
pleine session parlementaire en plein
budget alors c'est compliqué moi je
serais plutôt alors dès qu'on parle de
football bien sûr j'adore ma sélection
française et je la supporte mais quelque
part je suis plus italien vous voyez et
donc en Italie du coup bah oui mais une
coupe du monde sans les Italiens n'est
pas une Coupe du Monde 2 en Italie on
arrête des débats parlementaires contre
la Squadra azur joue et en France on
devrait faire la même chose à l'évidence
bon voilà c'est je vous rappelle pour le
pour le prochain match de l'équipe de
France votre pronostic elle ira jusqu'où
cette équipe de France le pronostic du
match là je sais pas trop vous dire
parce que c'est un match un petit peu
plus
confiance dans Didier Deschamps pour que
il sache gérer un groupe et nous emmener
je l'espère au bout
merci à vous merci d'avoir
exactement
de la Fondation droit animal et puis on
ira en Camargue aussi à la rencontre de
ceux qui vivent de la culture taurine ce
sera à suivre dans 20 minutes maintenant
mais d'abord on va écrire notre prochain
invité cet art de robinet qui nous
rejoindre